welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is the breakdown of the
new may the fourth trailer for obi-wan
kenobi on disney plus we get our first
partial looks at darth vader in this
series and lots of auramesh to translate
so let's go through this frame by frame
let's go
the coming we start off by hearing part
of the instrumentation of duel of the
fates
but the melody has been adjusted
somewhat john williams is actually
returning to contribute a new theme for
the series but most of the music is
being composed by natalie holt who did
an amazing job with the music of loki
and an even better job egging simon
cowell to protest how reality tv was
ruining the music industry true pax look
it up good for you natalie a shuttle
descends to the new planet on this
series daiyu described as a hong
kong-like setting the inquisitor named
the fifth brother sung kang leads the
squad of storm troopers into this market
where in the last trailer i translated
all the signs to things like market and
gunkin snacks and milk
actually there's another shot from this
location where it looks like it's haas
market onto the next clip
stay hidden
or we will not survive
[Music]
here the grand inquisitor rupert friend
leads the fifth brother and reva the
second sister played by moses ingram who
did an amazing job in the tragedy
macbeth they're walking down the street
of maz eisley on tatooine and i love how
they just park their shuttle in the
middle of the goddamn street instead of
a nearby spaceport because hey they are
inquisitors they can do whatever the
hell they want all inquisitors were
former jedi or force sensitive recruits
and the grand inquisitor was actually
confirmed to be one of those jedi temple
guards during the trials of ahsoka tano
and barasathi and clone wars that led to
ahsoka leaving the jedi order so this
guy was a direct witness to how full of
crap the jedi order is rebels season one
shows the grand inquisitor at his most
dastardly using the corpse of barasovi's
former master luminara unduli to set a
trap for kanan and ezra this series may
actually show the moment he captures and
tortures her i mean i would i would hate
to see that but it'd be cool to see a
luminar cameo but just you know
for a bad reason then we see another
shot of obi-wan gazing out at the large
homestead with ten-year-old luke
skywalker played by grant feely wearing
a pod racer helmet is he dreams of being
a pilot and one day killing hundreds of
thousands of imps in a single shot onto
the next clip leave us alone when the
time comes he must be trained
like you trained his father
so joel edgerton as uncle owen lars
tells obi-wan to back off now there are
actually several moments from the comics
in which obi-wan helped or rescued young
luke and owen actually right around when
this series is said obi-wan will save
owen from the wookiee black crusadin
whom we just saw on the book of boba
fett and that incident was how bk got
that lightsaber burn scar over his eye
so who knows we could even see that
backstory adapted here on this show
either way obi-wan has not been leaving
them alone nor will he stop i gotta
share with you a couple of my pet peeves
people on their phones during a movie
theater a streaming service buffering
during an important scene and soggy
socks everybody hates soggy socks to
banish soggy socks forever wear some
slick comfortable vessy shoes thanks to
bessie for sponsoring this video besties
are the perfect everyday shoe they're
sustainably made knit sneakers that are
100 waterproof they're made with this
dime-a-tex material that's just super
easy to clean with just a rinse of water
oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are bone
dry like the dune sea
thanks messy if you're experiencing wet
or muddy spring weather right now
bessies can help you slay the soggy
socks forever bessies are my go-to shoes
by my door check them out in the link
below for a pair of your own vessy shoes
obi-wan is pushing for luke to be
trained perhaps wary that luke's force
sensitivity is bound to be detected on
some sith holocron and luke will need to
defend himself against inquisitors who
come to find him owen really has the
best response
your lesson plan produced the galaxy's
worst war criminal hard pass and we just
gotta point out that maybe it's luck or
because of these movies that the show
now gets to have ewan mcgregor and joel
edgerton two of like the best working
actors acting off each other in a star
wars thing both of them doing such a
good job making it so natural but also
evoking the tonality of the actors in
the 77 film i'm just so excited to see
these two share a screen again let's
move on
you still want kenobi
he's gone
[Music]
maybe you've been looking in the wrong
places
so reverend walks across the deck of
this fortress inquisitorius the
partially underwater base of the
inquisitors on the ocean world of nur
actually relocated here after leaving
coruscant now really a secret base and
of course the major location of the jedi
fallen order game this remains the base
of operation for the inquisitors as they
do the bidding for darth vader to hunt
down every jedi run away after order 66
and every force sensitive kid hanging
overhead reva are some thai fighters
ready to deploy and reba joins the fifth
brother as well as endear varma as that
imperial officer her badge actually
makes her a colonel and then on the far
left i think that might be simone kessel
playing another inquisitor kind of looks
like the seventh sister who in star wars
rebels accompanies the fifth brother in
that whole malachor story line with maul
now on their table they reviewed this
planet and if you zoom in enhance you
can actually see some aurabesh there
which translates this planet to mapuzo
which is actually an obscure planet in
star wars canon from the mid-rim coming
from the alliance intelligence reports
the 1995 star wars role-playing game
which was the location of the mapuzo
break-in where a rhodian bounty hunter
named vadon lenator was believed to have
been a part of that break-in that's all
we really know about puzzle but i love
that they're bullying actual planet
names from star wars lore and making
them important now now behind them are
some red shelves that look like
lightsabers i assume one's recovered
from the jedi that they have hunted
which reminds us a lot of the way
grievous would collect lightsabers from
jedi that he had disarmed or killed so
creepy that they put them on display
like this then obi-wan rain is iope in
the desert then a shot of these pods
blasting away from the portraits
inquisitorius and up out of the
atmosphere of nur could these be runaway
jedi prisoners finally escaping the
fortress and then reva looks out at the
planet of daiyu on her left is a neon
sign translating to milk then in blue in
the distance that actually translates to
jawas market and over there there's a
shootout happening presumably the same
one that obi-wan is involved with
against some of the bounty hunters next
clip i want every lone life and bounty
hunter
to squeeze him
[Music]
okay a transmission arrives showing
obi-wan's file photo from the jedi
archives i assume around the era of
revenge of the sith the orbesh
translates to transmitting then wanted
obi-wan kenobi offenses high treason
bounty upon capture and if jedi mugshots
like this pop up on the show really
think this could be how we see other
quick cameos of a number of runaway jedi
like yoda ashoka tano calcustus caleb
doom luminar unduly a mysterious
floating egg cradle that none of the
jedi opened in the temple
so river wants to send some bounty
hunters after obi-wan and there's a
quick shot of this lone droid i think
this might be four loam the droid bounty
hunter who showed up in empire strikes
back along with boba vet and boss as
part of that crew that vader recruited
to find han solo kenobi tussles with a
horned zabrak and a real fun sweater and
then a shot of reva and the fortress
lights that were drawn and she's flanked
by purge troopers these are also from
fallen order obi-wan then takes down
some stormtroopers while an imperial
probe droid is wrecked behind him and he
fires a blaster so uncivilized you
cannot use a lightsaber that would out
him as a jedi then that droid labeled
ned takes a blast while it looks like he
and a strong trooper might be getting
force pulled and then a shot of
kamehameha nanjiani's character so he is
not voiced in a droid he is playing a
live-action character and he looks
terrified i am guessing he is a runaway
jedi who might come into contact with
obi-wan we're gonna get a new adorable
droid model with some mouse ears and
then the shot of bravo screaming after
obi-wan warning him that vader will find
him and we actually see this badass in
the next section
[Music]
so vader's robotic arm gets twisted onto
the stump where you can actually see his
skin looking burnt and pale and then a
shot of vader's midsection as his
breathing apparatus gets plugged in and
yeah my dudes these are prods actually
jabbing into his abdomen connecting with
his lungs it's incredibly painful kind
of like the needles that are in his
helmet that fuse into his brain it helps
feed his rage making him a more powerful
sith and making him one with the suit
more machine than man and in addition to
that iconic puff of vader's breath i
love that they include that high
frequency whistle that we heard when the
mask was first lowered onto his face and
revenge of the synth
and he had the final title melody evokes
the imperial march
[Applause]
[Music]
but unlike the last trailer which formed
the disney plus logo with obi-wan's blue
lightsaber this one cuts it with red now
reminder that every week tom and
bechtold and i break down the biggest
star wars news on wikileaks so join us
next week as we're going to talk about
this trailer in even greater depth
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following the rockstars and
subscribe to new rockstar for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you